friction between unconventional special
advisors and senior civil servants
is not a new thing let's talk to one of
the most
talked about cuckoos in whitehall's nest
tony blair's former director of
communications
alastair campbell now uh alice campbell
listening to dominic cummings i could
hear the voice of a highly intelligent
charismatic individual sitting at the
heart of government
who'd arrived in number 10 at the right
hand of the prime minister with a
mission
only to find himself in the glare of the
media
unable to uh utterly frustrated by the
shortcomings of
of whitehall and the mendacity of some
of his own political colleagues
does that feel in any way like a
familiar story to you
well only up to the point where you got
to the end there because i think when
we're talking about
mendacity dominic cummings is right up
there with boris johnson not least in
the brexit campaign
and i guess the equivalent i would only
compare myself
if i felt that after my time in downing
street i came out and trashed everything
that
that tony blair and gordon brown stood
for and did
and i will never do that because i think
they were committed public servants who
did a lot of good for the country
and i think what dominic cummings
testimony even accepting as bob kerslake
says he's a pretty unreliable witness
however what he said is borne out by
what lots of us have been saying for
some time
that this whole pandemic has been
scarred the government handling has been
scarred
by the character of the prime minister
by his inability to
to govern in a rational clear sensible
way
to appreciate systems to work with those
systems
and i thought it's interesting bob said
the point about we've got to be more
long-term
worry less about the day-to-day media i
thought one of the most telling parts of
dominic cummings
testimony was when he said and it's
something i've thought that boris
johnson is basically a journalist
and cummings said he wakes up every
morning has a flick through the papers
thinks what are they gonna what should
we do to sort of you know stay in the
story today
and he actually did that thing about
rubbing his fingers feeling the wind and
that is not government that is not
leadership and i think what cummings
exposed
is that if the country elects somebody
like johnson as prime minister
then the country is going to pay a very
heavy price for that we paid it in this
pandemic
let's leave aside the question of
whether all journalists
behave in that way alastair i think i
know some who actually read
the newspapers and and so on but
do you i get your point about johnson's
johnson but the truth
is it doesn't feel like the country
really agrees with you
even after cummings's testimony this
week
opinion polls have conservatives between
10 and 18 points ahead
and indeed in some polls they've
increased their lead post comings
well listen i honestly don't care about
the polls i care about what i think
about the country
and where the country is heading with
this prime minister and this cabinet
and you were talking there to some of
the principles of government with lord
kurzlek
well let me just go through the
principles that are meant to govern
standards in public life the nolan
principles honesty
openness which bob talked about
objectivity
selflessness integrity accountability
and leadership by example
i think johnson only scores on the last
one in that it leads by the example
that tells his cabinet ministers they
can be as useless as gavin williamson
they can break the ministerial code as
often as pretty patel they can
lie in the way that cummings says that
the hancock has
and none of them will get held to
account for that because johnson doesn't
want to get help them held to account
because he's the worst of the lot when
it comes to dishonesty in public life so
the polls i think are a reflection of
all sorts of things they're reflection
about the state of the opposition
they're a reflection of the success of
the vaccination program and people
feeling maybe maybe maybe we're just
coming out of this
this hell they're also a reflection of
the fact that i think the media
does not hold this government to account
nor does parliament frankly
does not hold this government to account
in the way that they should i think the
media has become incredibly supine in
its coverage of the government
and even on the coming stuff yes
wall-to-wall coverage
but then by the weekend it's oh well who
cares what dominic cummings think the
sun's shining
vaccination program is going well
johnson's got married let's just move on
and i think the country's just got to
decide do we care
about the fact that we have a government
and a prime minister that has comings
and i agree with him this
they are directly responsible for tens
of thousands of deaths do we care about
that or not
do we care that a prime minister stands
up in parliament you've now got that
video from peter stevanovic
over 20 million views hardly anybody in
the mainstream media covering it
where they set out we talk about has he
broken the ministerial code he breaks
the ministerial code virtually every
time he stands up in parliament they're
meant to tell the truth
and this is what populism has done to
our politics
i we could talk about um your views uh
about uh this this government forever
and
you know you know i you've been pretty
clear let's let's put it that way
on that but let's just uh talk about
some of the underlying substantive
questions here some of the ones that
i've talked
i was talking to bob kerslaker about
about the nature of government because
you've been inside it
one new labour minister complained why i
think while you were still
there that he thought that when you got
into government
there was this great machine and you're
if you're a minister
you pull a lever and the machine whirs
into life
and stuff happens and changes take place
and what he discovered within months was
that you pull a lever
and it wasn't connected to anything and
nothing
happens is that um sound about right to
you
no it doesn't and also i think that's a
bit naive because if you think about how
we got into power
in 1997 was partly recognizing a lot of
the weaknesses in the system that if you
like we were up against and i think that
you know to be fair to the civil service
at the time yes there was some who were
obstructive yes there were some who were
difficult yes there were some who
weren't you know very good at the job
but a lot of them were and i think what
you've you know sorry to keep going back
to the current
government compared to a kind of what i
would call a rational government and a
sensible professional government
what happened was that when there was
clear direction from ministers
i think actually the civil service was
you know was broadly responsive
and i think one of the problems in the
pandemic has been the relentlessness of
the kind of mixed messaging
people not really knowing what they're
meant to be saying what they're meant to
be doing
johnson just making it up on the hoof
whereas actually listen there were lots
of situations
and tony blair famously made that speech
about the scars on his back
about the difficulties of getting public
service reform
however we did deliver a lot of public
service reform
not least with the help of the best of
the best in the civil service but where
i go with bob
kersley by the way i do think we've got
to move away from all this language we
talk about the rolls-royce civil service
we have the best armed forces in the
world we have some of the best
but i think that we this british
exceptionalism is a is really not a
sensible way to kind of approach issues
like
the ones you're talking about let me
take it let me take you back to those
new labor years at the scandal um you
know you say you
they did terrific job in some respects
they weren't always that complimentary
about you
i mean i heard a former cabinet
secretary on the radio this week
saying that some of the roth set in with
the sofa government
of the blair regime and you were one of
the people on the sofa
uh some of the people in whitehall would
say this is all
your fault well i don't know who that
was and
and i think that the whole thing about
sofa government is it was just a
complete
nonsense tony blair ran a very tight
ship
and he embraced the civil service i
remember one of the first things he did
was took me and jonathan powell into a
room
jonathan who was the other special
adviser who was a was we were given
these
special dispensations to instruct civil
servants and he was very very clear we
work with these people we don't work
against them
and i think you'd find very very few
people who worked with me
or with jonathan powell or any of the
others who were in there one of the
things i'm
most proud of actually is the people
nobody who's ever worked for me in the
civil service
has ever come out and criticized the way
that we dealt with them
and the way that we worked with them and
you know i think the other point bob
made
very quickly gone can i guide you one
other question sorry
of course which is about the the effect
of the last year
there have been stories this week about
effect of on people's mental health and
i know this is something that
you are particularly uh concerned about
if you've got any thoughts about
what we ought to be think doing going
forward
well i am really worried about this
because i i understand that the
government has
you know its main focus has been on in
dealing with the pandemic
but you know the royal college of
psychiatrist has warned about mental
illness being the
the second pandemic and you know that
whether that overstates it or not i
think we all know
that there are going to be long-term
consequences from this on mental health
for students who couldn't study for
children who couldn't go to school
for business people who've lost their
business but people who've lost their
jobs
for people who've lost their loved ones
and not been able to say
farewell all of these things have
psychological impact and
i do sense that with this government
from matt hancock and
johnson and they they just want this is
populism they want to say that
everything's fine
well actually things are not going to be
fine for some time to come and the only
way we're going to address that and get
a strategy for that
is actually if they recognize it and the
governments that are doing best
in relation to the the health
consequences the mental health
consequences the pandemic
are those like new zealand like germany
like taiwan where they've actually said
from the word go
there are going to be mental health
consequences from this and i wish that
our government would take the same
approach
alex campbell thank you very much indeed